the baltic countries in poland
this means that we will have eight
multinational nato bat groups
all along the eastern flank
from the baltic to the black sea
we face a new reality for our security
so we must reset our deterrence and
defense
for the longer term
tomorrow nato leaders will reaffirm our
support to ukraine
ukraine has the right to self-defense
under the nato
under the u.n charter
and we are helping ukrainians to uphold
this fundamental right
since 2014 allies have trained ukraine's
armed forces
and significantly strengthen their
capabilities
they are putting that training into
practice now on the front lines
with great bravery
in the last months allies have stepped
up military support
providing anti-tank
and air defense systems
drones
fuel and ammunition
as well as financial aid
and hosting millions of refugees
tomorrow
i expect allies will agree to provide
additional support
including
cyber security assistance
as well as equipment to help ukraine
protect against chemical
biological
and radiological and nuclear threats
president putin's invasion is brutal
and the human suffering is horrifying
and painful to witness
we are determined to do all we can to
support ukraine
but we have a responsibility to ensure
that the war does not escalate beyond
ukraine
and become a conflict between nato and
russia
this would cause even more death and
even more destruction
i also expect we will agree to step up
tailored support for other partners at
risk from
a russian pressure
including georgia
and bosnia zigovina
working together
with the european union we must help
them to uphold the sovereignty
and the right to make independent
decisions
we face a fundamentally changed security
environment where authoritarian powers
are increasingly prepared to use force
to get their way
so i expect we will also address the
role of china in this crisis
beijing has joined moscow in questioning
the right of independent nations to
choose to choose trump off
china has provided russia with political
support
including by spreading
blatant lies and disinformation
and allies are concerned that china
could provide material support
for the russian invasion
i expect leaders will call on china to
live up to its responsibilities
as a member of the u.n security council
refrain from supporting russia's war
effort and join the rest of the world in
calling for an immediate
peaceful end to this war
we also call on belarus to end its
complicity in putin's invasion
the decisions we take tomorrow will have
far reaching implications
major reinforcements to our security
will require major investments in
defence
so i expect allies will agree to
redouble their efforts to invest more
there is a new sense of urgency
because we cannot take peace for granted
from the start of this crisis europe and
north america have stood together united
in nato
and we may and we remain united
opposing russia's aggression
supporting ukraine
and protecting all allies
and with that i'm ready to take your
questions
okay we'll start with uh cnn lady over
there
thank you natasha bertram with cnn
um mr secretary general estonia has been
calling for nato to build up a permanent
force in the region that is capable of
stopping a russian offensive offensive
but the nato russia founding act
technically does not allow the alliance
to establish permanent military basing
in so-called new member states and so
i'm wondering if you believe that it's
time to repeal the nato-russia founding
act given its invasion of ukraine and
i'm also wondering estonia's defense
chief had also said that nato should get
involved directly if russia uses weapons
of mass destruction like chemical
weapons and i'm wondering if these kinds
of red lines and how nato would react if
they were crossed are going to be
discussed
um
first of all we have to remember that
we over the last weeks
have
deployed a substantial number of
combat-ready troops to the eastern part
alliance
unprecedented
nato presence
in the baltic region including in
estonia
and i've been in estonia myself and i've
seen the nato troops there we actually
doubled the size of the nato battlegroup
and we have doubled the number of
battlegroups in eastern part alliance
so not only double the size but also
double the number of battle groups
close to 40 000 uh troops on the direct
nato command and then on top of that
increased presence by the united states
and others
on
within the bilateral arrangements so in
totality this is a significant
reinforcement
of our presence in the east
including in estonia
with air sea and land forces
and we have
we are ready and we are there to protect
and defend allies relative to uh respond
massively to any potential a threat
attack against any nato allied country
this has already happened so this is
this is this reinforcement has only
taken place
and we will then also tomorrow make
decisions uh and they declare
that we have deployed four more battle
groups to uh to shore
hungary bulgaria and uh and and and
romania
then
there is a need
to also address the more long-term
consequences
so in addition to what we have already
done
i expect also allied leaders tomorrow to
agree a tasking to our military
commanders
to look into the more longer-term
consequences for our deterrence on
defense there is a need to reset our
deterrence on events
and i expect that to be a substantial
increase our presence for the long term
and we will do what is necessary to
ensure that we protect and defend all
allies and ensure that
nato
provides credible deterrence on defence
uh to all countries including uh in uh
estonia
russia has walked away from the
nato-russia funding act
they have violated it again and again
they violated clearly back in 2014 when
they
illegally annexed crimea
and started to destabilize eastern
ukraine
and they have violated it when they
moved into georgia in 2008 and of course
the invasion of ukraine
now is a
blatant violation of the nato russia
funding act
on um
on chemical weapons
so
first of all any use of chemical weapons
would would
totally change the nature of the
conflict
and it will be a blatant violation of
international law
and will have far reaching consequences
i think and i think that's the most
important message to convey
uh that uh
any use of chemical weapons is is
absolutely unacceptable and will have
far reaching consequences
go to nbc lady in reds in the middle
yeah
nbc news
secretary general
president biden in leaving washington
just said that he believes that the use
of chemical weapons by russia in ukraine
is a real threat
you have just said that we cannot take
peace for granted and there is no sign
certainly
that
vladimir putin is taking diplomacy
seriously
and here we have president zielinski who
will plead again with nato
for admission to nato
if chemical weapons are used in ukraine
how would it be morally acceptable
for nato to ignore president zlinski's
plea
for nato commission
for nato for nato admission
to ignore his plea
to be admitted to nato thank you
[Music]
what we see in in ukraine now is
is really painful it's horrific
and and we see the brutal consequences
of a full fledge generation
of an
peaceful independent sovereign nation
and that was the reason why nato allies
have stepped up support
including with advanced air defense
systems anti-tank systems
different types of weapons
ammunition and and we are providing
unprecedented support to ukraine
and this is actually also comes on top
of what we have done for many years
because
nato allies have chained tens of
thousands of ukrainian troops
since 2014
and they are now on the front line
uh fighting the
invading forces
and it is first and foremost
the courage of the ukrainian forces and
the ukrainian people and the ukrainian
leadership that has enabled them to
resist and to fight back against the
russian invasion but at the same time
the support they have received for many
years
has proven extremely
important and critical and i
expect that when allah lead this meet
tomorrow they will
address how to further strengthen our
support to to
to ukraine
um
nato membership is not on on the agenda
but support to ukraine is absolutely on
top of our agenda and will be one of the
main main issues to be addressed
tomorrow
okay sky
thank you
secretary general thank you very much
mark stone from sky news um
could you explain or could you outline
how nato defends itself against a
nuclear attack
because it's clear that on russian state
media
they are openly propagandists pundits
people close to the kremlin are now
talking
in pretty straight and stark terms about
a nuclear attack how does nato defend
itself against a nuclear attack thank
you
russia must stop its nuclear saber
rattling
this is dangerous and it is
irresponsible
nato is there to protect and defend all
allies
and we convey a very clear message to
russia that the nuclear war
can not be won and should never be
fought
and
it just highlights the importance of
ending the war in ukraine because we
need to do everything we can to prevent
the war
from escalating beyond ukraine and
becoming even more deadly and even more
dangerous than
what we see today
any use of nuclear weapons will
fundamentally change
the nature of the conflict
and russia must understand that a
nuclear war should never be fought and
never and they can never win a nuclear
war
this is actually something that russia
has agreed to again and again
and the the continued nuclear saber
rattling from
russia the the nuclear rhetoric is
actually contradicting what they have
stated in the eu and in other
formats uh agreeing that we should do
whatever we can to prevent a nuclear
conflict okay al jazeera
secretary general staying with weapons
of mass destruction you said in your
opening statement on chemical and
biological weapons
that you were thinking of equipment to
protect ukraine can you give us more
details of what you're going to be
proposing to the leaders tomorrow
so we have provided different types of
support also when it comes to
different measures to protect
against
chemical
weapons and i expect allies to look into
how they can step up and provide more
uh
equipment to
protect and defend against the chemical
weapons
i think i don't think it's useful if i
go into all the details part because
allies will discuss this tomorrow but
also partly because i think that when it
comes to the details about exactly what
kind of support we provide
it's actually not always the best thing
to be too detailed about that we provide
support we are stepping up our support
and we are uh
concerned about
the possibility of use of chemical
weapons or biological weapons we've also
seen not only the nuclear rhetoric from
the russian side but also these false
claims that that ukraine supported by
nato allies are producing and preparing
for the use of chemical weapons this is
an absolute false
accusation but it it it may be
a way for them to invite try to create
the pretext for their use of chemical
weapons
russia has used chemical agents before
against their own opposition and also on
nato allied territory in salzburg and
russia was of course
part of the use of chemical weapons in
syria they facilitated and supported the
assad regime which has actually used
chemical weapons several times so we are
concerned and that's also reason why we
are
ready and and and will address tomorrow
uh
ways to provide support to ukraine to
protect themselves against the use of
chemical weapons and let me add that of
course this is extremely
serious for the people of ukraine
but
any use of chemical weapons or
biological weapons
males have died of consequences for nato
allied countries people living there the
contamination um the spread
of chemical or biological agents used in
ukraine may have died consequences also
for the population living and living in
nato other countries in europe so it
just underscores the seriousness of
our concerns okay we'll go to interfax
ukraine the lady in red with glasses in
the middle thank you
thank you so much irena summer news
agency interface ukraine secretary
general
um according to nato and u.s officials
below russia is ready to send the troops
into the war
against ukraine what it will change for
ukrainians and what it will change for
nato
and my second question is about
coalition
mass media already reported that poland
leadership
are ready
to put tomorrow for discussion a
proposal to send peacekeeping mission to
ukraine they mentioned nato peacekeeping
mission to ukraine but how about
coalition um coming back to
2003 a coalition were created from three
nato alliance and one non-nato country
in iraq
do you think it will be a good solution
to create a coalition of country who
wants to fight for ukraine without nato
involvement thank you
so first of belarus
belarus has
been a complicit to this invasion from
the start
actually before the start because
belarus allowed its territory to be used
as a
ground for mobilizing
massing troops that invaded
ukraine
and
belarus continues to
enable
the invasion
by providing the territory airfields
military infrastructure
bases but also by allowing russia to use
palestine airspace to launch attacks
every night every day against
ukrainian cities again against ukrainian
civilians against the
uh
the the ukrainian nation
so ukraine sorry belarus is already
already heavily involved in the way that
uh it has
been a
complicit and and and has supported the
uh the the russian uh invasion and of
course we call on belarus to stop doing
exactly that
uh and not be used by russia uh to
conduct this brutal war against a
neighbor
ukraine
um
when it comes to forces
nato is not part of the conflict we
provide support ukraine but we're not
part of the conflict we we help
ukraine without holding the right for
self-defense which is enshrined in the
u.n charter
but uh nato will not send troops uh into
into ukraine
we have to understand that
it is extremely important to provide
support to ukraine and we are stepping
up but at the same time it is also
extremely important to prevent that this
conflict becomes a full-fledged war
between nato and
and
russia and therefore it has been a very
clear
message from nato allies that we will
not send troops to ukraine
we have a polish radio lady at the back
yes
thank you very much honor but
the polish public broadcaster
secretary general if i may ask about
again about enhancing the poet presence
on the eastern flank is it a time to
consider or to decide to enlarge the
battalions that are in baltic states and
poland into the brigade
groups and also
follow up to the to the question
concerning nuclear threats repeated
again and again by russia
is there a possibility to for the
leaders to prepare a kind of a plan
just in case thank you very much
first on the nuclear threat nato has
plans in place to protect all allies
against any threat
but our main message is that russia
should stop this dangerous irresponsible
nuclear rhetoric
but
but but but let there be no doubt about
our readiness to protect
and defend allies against any threat any
attack
and of course we have plans in place to
do exactly that
um
on uh
on
the size
well first of all
so
before this invasion we had four
battlegroups battalion sized
now we have doubled the size of those
battlegroups in poland in lithuania in
estonia and in the in in latvia
and then we have doubled the number of
battle groups
uh with the new bat groups
in slovakia hungary bulgaria and romania
which
the leaders will then announce
tomorrow
and there are more
in poland there are also additional
troops from the us
uh i recently visited
the vasque air base i met with u.s
and and other pilots
so there has been significant increase
of
of of nato allies especially united
states presence in eastern part of the
alliance this is our
immediate response has already taken
place
then i think we need to separate that a
bit from the more longer term adaptation
our alliance
and we will spend some time now from now
on to the summit uh in june to make
more fundamental decisions are on our
deterrence and defense it's about
resetting our deterrence and defense
especially in the east
and there i expect that a part of that
will be a significant increase
of our presence on the ground in the
eastern part of the lines
for the long term
so
immediately we have done a lot
then we will start the process of more
long-term changes no returns and events
which will be lasting and uh and and and
most likely uh will then include also a
significant increase of the size or the
presence of
uh the nato multinational
forces in the eastern part alliance
including in the poland
okay we'll go to chas from ukraine
gentlemen here
gentlemen in blue yeah
secretary general i have
do you believe
in the successful and fruitful
fruitful summit tomorrow
taking on account the position of
hungary
as you know that they
are going to block
the main issues you will put
on the table tomorrow concerning
uh
of the help to ukraine
well i believe it will be an important
summit tomorrow an extraordinary to
summit in an extraordinary security
situation where we face the biggest
security threat
for a generation since since actually
the end of the second world war
um and um
and therefore i
i believe this is an important meeting
and i'm confident that allies would
agree
uh on important issues including under
the importance of providing support to
ukraine uh strengthening our own
deterrence and defense and also provide
support to all the partners which are
now under pressure from russia for
instance georgia and bosnia herzegovina
and and i
expect all allies to agree all 30.
okay we'll go to politico
the lady here
thank you second round
um thank you very much secretary general
i'm lily baier from politico um some
nato allies have expressed an interest
in having you potentially stay on for an
extra year in your current role given
the current situation would you be open
to staying in your current job another
year thank you
this is for 30 allies to decide
my focus is on preparing the summit
tomorrow
in the midst of the most
serious security situation
uh we have been in for decades and
that's my focus and then i leave it to
the allies to decide on the other things
okay we'll go to uh afghan voice ladies
green
thank you very much joanna lelomo said
it from brussels morning
i'm sorry i i know this is very tough
situation i would like to ask questions
about afghanistan
which is disappear from meetings and
also from news
unfortunately
actually today millions of girls and
women were
waiting to open the schools and
university in afghanistan but
unfortunately it's not happen
and i believe the taliban as a tourist
group they never change because they
didn't cut their time with al qaeda and
also with akony network
so
in a country the woman or disappear from
the society and also there is no woman
right human right and also freedom of
expression and also
liberty at all
they are killing rapping and also
torturing and uh imprison the people in
afghanistan
why is it acceptable and attractive for
for for eu and also for nato thank you
i think it is very important that we
don't forget afghanistan
and
it is especially important that we don't
forget that
education is fundamentally human right
and of course that also applies for
girls for women
and
it was one of the biggest achievements
of the last 20 years
that millions of afghan
girls
were able to attend school and to get
education
and the any uh
attempt to deny goals in afghanistan
education
uh will be
a violation of what taliban has promised
and we have to help them accountable for
what they promised and their commitments
including
on the right for education to
women
therefore i agree with the
disappointment expressed by
the united nations
and i also
strongly
believe that we
must continue
to
support
all afghans who are
working to uphold the right for
uh for human rights
for the freedom of speech but including
also the right for education for uh
women
financial times
yes over there thanks thank you uh thank
you so much secretary general you
mentioned um
china
uh do you personally consider china to
be an ally of russia in this conflict
and what would you like to see from nato
member states uh in terms of real
actions that could pressure china into
ceasing its support for russia thank you
so what we have seen is that china has
not been able to
condemn the invasion they abstained the
even
general assembly on the vote on the
resolution clearly condemning
the invasion we also see in that
chinese
state
authorities have
spread some some of the same lies about
ukraine
uh and about nato um and in that way
provide the political support to uh to
russia and of course for nato it is a
particular concern that uh china now for
the first time has questioned some of
the key principles for our security
including the right for every nation in
europe to choose on path because in the
joint statement between president xi and
president putin
they actually uh
together
um uh state that they uh are against any
further enlargement of
nato that's new part of that they work
so closely together and partly that
china joins russia in trying to deny
european nations the freedom to choose
their own path
and therefore we call on russia and i
expect the leaders when they meet
tomorrow to call on russia
sorry to call on china
to condemn the invasion and to
engage in diplomatic efforts to find a
peaceful uh
way to end this war as soon as possible
okay we had not provide material support
i'm sorry
ukrainian state tv
ukrainian state tv atv my question about
do you know about real ukraine's defense
needs and do you have clear priorities
what ukrainians need today do you have
do you know about the disappointing
disappoint of ukrainians in nato now and
how do you explain your strategy to
average people in ukraine who now under
shelling in kiev and in other cities
what we see in ukraine is horrific it's
it's it's painful even for us to watch
and then of course it's even worse for
those who are there
and the and and the human suffering and
the scale of violence uh is something we
have not seen since the second world war
in uh in europe
um
nato allies are in close contact
at different levels with
ukraine with president zielenski with
the ministers
we had a ukrainian
defense minister participating in our
defence ministry last week tomorrow uh
presidency will address the nato summit
and
as we all know president zielinski and
other ukraine officials are addressing
different uh
political bodies in different
countries
across the alliance
almost daily and by doing that and by
having the close
contact at many different levels we also
are informed about the needs
for different types of help financial
support humanitarian support but also of
course military support and allies are
stepping up with military with financial
with humanitarian
support
then
then then
we are aware of uh
because this is something which
president zielenski and the ukrainian
officials have expressed
several time to us
that they are grateful for the support
but they want us to do even more
we are ready to step up in many ways
but for instance
on
the call for a no-fly zone we have
stated that
we are not going to impose a no-fly zone
because we believe
that that will
most likely trigger a full-fledged war
between nato and the ukraine
a no-fly zone means that we need to
take out russian air defense systems in
russia which are covering the airspace
over ukraine and it means that we have
to be ready to shoot down
russian planes
and that will most likely lead to
full-fledged conflict so
we are in
regular almost daily contact with
ukraine ukraine is a highly valued
partner we have worked with ukraine for
many years i've been there many times
myself
um and it is horrific and and
and and really
hard to watch
uh and that's also the reason why allies
have
doesn't provide so much provides support
but also have imposed unprecedented
sanctions on russia
to
ensure that this wars ends
okay associated press
launch associated press on the the
battle groups please for hungary
slovakia romania and bulgaria
could you give us a sense of when
they're supposed to arrive i imagine
circumstances are urgent and how long
they might stay is this something that
we're looking at for several years or
just until this conflict has died down
and then within that uh there was a
question i think hungary didn't
necessarily want other troops there
how's that going to work thank you so
these bad groups are now actually uh
there
we are increasingly they are becoming
more and more integrated and more and
more operational
so but the forces are uh all that is
also at least to a large extent although
they're there um uh um
and they're going to be nato
multinational battle groups um
there will be of course
an important component of the national
uh
home defense forces we've been part of
the battlegroup but then will be other
nato allies also contributing forces
again this is part of our immediate
reaction so this is something which has
which is happening now
uh as part together with with all the
other things we have done
as a
it's hundreds hundreds of thousands of
nato troops on heightened alert
roughly 100 000 u.s troops in in in
europe now many of them in eastern part
of the alliance
um um and that is significantly more
than before the crisis and then around
40 000 uh nate troops on the direct nato
command
and all of this is is the immediate
response to the
to the russian invasion of ukraine
we will we will have that in place as
long as necessary
but in parallel with that we have
started the process
to
reset for the long term of the turns on
events because
it is already today possible to say that
this invasion this brutal wall war in
ukraine would have
long-term consequences for our security
it's a new normal for our security and
nato has to respond to that new reality
but that more long-term process will
also that process will take some more
weeks uh but we can do that because we
all have implemented a significant
reinforcement or presence in the east
and in parallel that we are addressing
more long-term changes including most
likely significant increased presence in
the air online at sea in the eastern
part of the alliance okay we'll take two
more questions wall street journal and
then we'll come down here to bloomberg
thank you very much dan michaels wall
street journal
when you look at how successfully the
ukrainian troops have
have been able to hold back the russians
in many places much the surprise the
russians apparently
partly thanks to training from nato and
nato member states
do you wish that over recent years nato
and its members have been able actually
to do more do you feel that if if more
had been done that the situation could
be different thank you
first of all i would like to commend the
courage the professionalism of the
ukrainian armed forces
i have met them
in ukraine
and uh
we are all aware that
compared to where
they were back in 2014 this is a totally
different
uh force than
uh
eight years ago
um
the ukrainian armed forces today it's
much bigger
much
better equipped much better trained much
better commanded
they are much better logistics
than they had back in 2014
and of course all of this combined with
the courage the high morale
is the reason why they are really able
to push back
and to stand up against
the uh much bigger russian
invasion
at the same time i think we did need to
remember that ukraine is a big nation
it's the biggest country in europe
and uh and more than 44 million people
so it's a significant nation
with a strong
army defense force
and of course i am it's important that
nato allies have provided support for
many years especially the united states
in canada and united kingdom but also
some other allies
and also uh believe it is important to
to understand that uh
that uh that this
nato has also provided support on
logistics on command on modernizing
their uh the
the security institutions into the
transformation of the ukraine armed
forces has been supported by also nato
as the institution and for instance the
awardee
the place that was attacked
is a place where we conducted
training and support for ukrainians i've
been there myself um and seen how nato
allies and nato for many years have
provided important support of course
it's always
in in inside possible to say that we
should have done even more uh but i
first of all i think the lesson learned
is that support and help over many years
have a significant impact as it had on
the ukrainian armed forces and second i
think it also is a lesson to be learned
about the importance of supporting other
partners which are under russian
pressure
thank you natalia josiah from bloomberg
i just want to go back to the the topic
of chemical weapons um you mentioned
last week
that um there was a risk that russia
could try to do this
under the cover of a false flag event
and today you're talking about allies
sending protective equipment what can
you tell us about the threat how has it
evolved is it becoming more urgent or
imminent thank you
we are concerned uh and we are concerned
because
we see the rhetoric
we see the attempts by russia to create
this pretext
and accuse us and ukraine for preparing
the use of chemical weapons
and we are concerned also because we
know that russia has
used chemical agents before
and they have supported assad and and
facilitate the facilitated use of
chemical weapons in in syria
uh at the same time
we all we also we also we were also open
about our concerns to to to to to
decrease the likelihood for any use of
uh
chemical weapons because that will
fundamentally change the nature of the
conflict it will be a blatant violation
of international
law and it will have severe consequences
in a way that it is important to
convey to russia
so they don't use any chemical weapons
in ukraine
both because that kind of of course
any use of chemical weapons will have
devastating consequences for ukraine but
it could also have
severe consequences for neighboring
countries because any contamination or
spread of chemical agents or biological
agents will of course also potentially
affect neighbors
thank you very much this concludes this
press conference we'll see you tomorrow
thank you thank you so much